kamala harris is on her first
foreign trip as u.s vice president her
mission is to address
undocumented migration to the u.s by
tackling root causes including
poverty and political oppression harris
has now arrived in mexico city for talks
with president andres manuel lopez
obrador
she traveled from guatemala where she
offered a message of hope to the people
of the country but
discouraged them from trying to cross
into the u.s
at the same time i want to be clear to
folks in this region who are thinking
about
making that dangerous trek
to the united states mexico border
do not come do not come
well one of the disagreements that
president lopez obrador and u.s vice
president kamala harris will discuss on
tuesday is
how to resolve the migration crisis
mexico has been pressuring washington to
increase
investment in central america to curb
the tide of migration from there
dw reporter aitor sayas traveled to the
city
of tapachula in southern mexico near the
border to guatemala
it's one of the keep arrival points for
undocumented migrants from
central america traveling north in the
hope of reaching the u.s
dania rios traveled from honduras to
mexico with her two daughters and two
nephews
they've just been detained at a
checkpoint in tapachula
and don't know where they will be taken
they arrived last monday we've been
hungry and slept in the park because we
had nowhere to sleep
just
trying to hold on none olga sanchez has
been running a shelter for migrants in
tapachula
for three decades she's noticed that
since u.s president joe biden took power
more and more women are arriving alone
with their children
there's a bottleneck in the north and a
bottleneck here we don't know what to do
but
people are still coming
[Music]
migrants are forced to seek asylum first
in mexico
before they can continue their journey
towards the u.s
the authorities estimate they'll receive
about 100 000 asylum applications this
year
that's more than double the number of
last year
the paperwork used to take about 20 days
to process
now it takes months
that's left thousands of migrants from
haiti and central america
stranded in tapachula struggling to
survive
several ngos say it's part of a
deliberate political strategy
to dissuade the migrants from leaving
their countries the un's refugee agency
says governments need to do more
we are calling for a greater effort from
all countries
it's not just one country that has to
deal with this situation
we're seeing it across the region and
all the leaders have to be involved
dania and her family spent all their
savings to flee the violence in their
neighborhood
anthony's father was recently killed by
gang members
the people who killed the boy's father
are threatening us too
we don't want to go back to honduras no
locked in this van and worried about
deportation
they fear they've invested everything
just to end up
back where they started
well for more let's speak to liz shulker
she's a u.s policy analyst at the
humboldt foundation here in berlin
so liz this is harris's first foreign
trip as vice president
what do you make of it so far
well this is a huge moment for her um
she
is a coming from the the congress the
senate background and this is going to
test her foreign policy chops
and she needs to do it very wisely so
kind of what i'm hearing
coming from the administration is to set
modest expectations
but a strong foundation so they're not
looking for her to eradicate
migrant policy or our uh relationship
with immigration
but to set things in place that moving
forward
signal the biden administration is
taking this very seriously
and uh vice president harris the right
person to lead that
now kamala harris is telling would-be
migrants rather bluntly
do not come that's quite a turnaround
from the welcoming tone we heard from
the biden administration initially
isn't it i'm not sure i would phrase it
like that
um you can both be more welcoming than
the previous administration
also more focused on human rights when
they do arrive in the country
but as the last segment showed there has
been a massive
uptick in migration and not only is that
untenable for the united states
but this is incredibly dangerous you
know the the loss of
life and the danger that they're putting
women and children in
is kind of uncounted we don't really
even know the full
scope of it so i think it's prudent to
kind of go to the source and say
this is both not an easy track and will
not be an easy arrival
um so don't just assume because it's the
biden administration
um that much is going to be different
than than the past decade
but that change in administration indeed
served as a
as a had a pulling effect on migration
if we could say that
but aside from telling would-be migrants
you're not wanted in the u.s on this
trip
what incentives is the vice president
offering for them to stay at home
i think that was the thrust of the act
the actual thrust of the trip and to lay
those foundations
so she not only met with government
officials she met with local ngos she
held a
roundtable on women's empowerment um
talked about
500 000 vaccines delivered to guatemala
from the u.s
so she's talking about these long
lasting foundations she wants she
mentioned several times
offering hope so how can we go to the
root cause
and help with economic stability
uh reducing violence and helping folks
not even have to take the journey in the
first place
let's talk about those factors driving
latin american migration
to the u.s poverty gang violence bad
governance
these are huge problems in central
america what's the biden
administration's
policy approach leads to those issues is
there a robust
policy in place
i think that's what's being rolled out
and i think they're taking it very
seriously
um the the chairman of the hispanic
caucus
in congress uh representative ruiz
talked about
he's really pushing the administration
to go to the root cause
um and i think that's really necessary
there's gonna be folks on the internet
that are very
unhappy with what she said and i think
they know that they knew this was a
risky thing to say
but they believe in a holistic approach
that's
targeting there has been stability
economic
um political and violence in the in
central america
for decades now so it's going to be a
massive overhaul so this is not
a one-trip glam stop that will fix
anything but how do we build a
sustainable future because they are our
neighbors
and so i think you're going to see a
really strong lasting
foundation of policies being rolled out
liz thank you so much that was liz
shulker
u.s policy analyst with the humboldt
foundation
thank you
you